Today we're going to examine would
the Lucy Lady Duff Gordon from this
incredibly famous case,
we will discuss implied promises and the
use of those promises as consideration
in the process. We'll also talk
about exclusive dealing contracts.
Lucy Lady Duff Gordon born Lucy Cristiana
Sutherland was a famous and innovative
British fashion designer
whose company Lucille Limited,
served an impressive array
of famous clients worldwide.
And Otis F would was a prominent New
York advertising agent by the way.
Uh, Lucy Lady Duff Gordon.
She was also rather notorious.
She's sailed on the titanic and
she and her husband Sir Cosmo,
were both saved by a lifeboat. Think of
her as kind of a car dash in a per day.
So in,
in 1915 wood and lady death,
Gordon signed a year long renewable
contract whereby would was given the
exclusive right to place lady
Duff Gordon's endorsement
on other designs and the
exclusive right to sell lady Duff Gordon's
own designs or licensed others to do
so. These rights, we're all subject
to a lady Duff Gordon's approval.
The contract provided that the
two parties would split equally.
All profits derive from this agreement.
However,
Lady Deaf Gordon then began listing
her products for sale in Sears Roebucks
catalog. And you can see one of
our advertisements right here
would allege that she did so without
informing them and withheld from him the
profits from the Sears Roebuck catalogs
and would then sued for his share of
these profits.
So here's a quiz.
The plaintiff argued that lady death,
Gordon breached her contractual promise
to would have exclusive dealing of
exclusivity by endorsing products and
earning money there from without the
plaintiff's knowledge.
And from the recital facts you just heard.
What did would promise in return to the
plaintiff in exchange for this plaintiff
promise of exclusivity?
Well,
the agreement gave would the
exclusive right to do certain things,
to place deaf Gordon's endorsement on
other's designs and to market products and
to grant licenses and,
and prescribed woods conduct
when doing those things.
But it's not clear that the contractual
terms actually required woods to endorse
market or license anything.
It was just his option.
So it wasn't clear what he was promising
in exchange for lady Duff Gordon's
promise of exclusivity.
That indeed was the basis of
Lady Duff Gordon's defense.
She argued that the party's agreement
did not constitute an enforceable
agreement because would did
not bind himself to anything.
The defendant argued, in other words,
that the contract lacked consideration.
The appellate division agreed reversing
a trial court judgment in favor of the
plaintiff.
Every promise on woods part that court
explained was dependent upon him actually
making endorsements,
Marketing Lady Duff Gordon's products or
granting licenses and quote nowhere in
the contract has he bound himself
to do any of these things.
The monumentally famous
judge Benjamin Cardozo,
who we already encountered
in Jacob and Young's v Kent,
wrote the opinion for the
New York Court of Appeals.
You get a sense from this opinion of his
ability to write memorable phrases such
as instinct with obligation
in this decision.
Cardoza seem to acknowledge that the
literal words of the party's agreement did
not convey any binding
obligation on woods part. Yet.
He asserted that the law has outgrown
its primitive stage of formalism when the
precise word was sovereigns Talus man,
and every slip fatal.
Even if a promise,
we're not explicit yet.
The whole writing may be instinct with
an obligation in perfectly expressed.
Cardoza found this was the case in the
agreement between wood and Lady Duff
Gordon.
There was an imperfectly expressed
or implied promise by wood to quote,
use reasonable efforts to place the
defendant's endorsements and market her
design.
How did cars Cardozo discern
such an implied promise?
Well,
first the fact that the
right the defending granted
was exclusive combined with
the term of compensation set forth in
the agreement was extremely important.
Cardozo insisted quote,
we are not to suppose that one party
was to be placed in the mercy of another
unquote.
If Lady Death,
Gordon granted would the sole right to
endorse products and market her designs
and would had no obligation
to do anything in return.
Lady Duff Gordon could drive no profit
if would chose not to exercise his right.
Rather Cardozo argued,
the acceptance of an exclusive deal
agency was an assumption of its duties,
a duty to make reasonable efforts.
Additionally,
the other terms of the contract
illuminates the intention
of the parties and the
intention supported a conclusion that the
plaintiff also had an obligation under
the agreement.
Those terms included recognition that
woods was in the business of placing
endorsements for quote.
The implication is that the plaintiff's
business organization will be used for
the purpose of for which it is adapted
unquote providing a monthly account of
all the money would received
and taking out all patents,
copyrights and trademarks as were
necessary to protect the rights and goods.
The agreement affected the implied
promise to use reasonable efforts to bring
profits and revenues into existence,
constituted consideration that created
an enforceable agreement and allowed the
plaintiff to recover.
For Lady Duff Gordon's breach.
The holding of this case is essentially
been codified as a default rule for
exclusive dealing contracts and
the uniform commercial code.
The UCC section two three Oh six two
reads a lawful agreement by either the
seller or the buyer for exclusive dealing.
The kind of goods concerned imposes
unless otherwise agreed and obligation by
the seller to use best efforts to supply
the goods and by the buyer to use best
efforts to promote their sale.
And the official comment
to this section says,
subsection two on exclusive dealing makes
explicit the commercial rule embodied
in this act under which parties to such
contracts are held to have impliedly
even when not expressly bound themselves
to use reasonable diligence as well as
good faith in their
performance of the contract.
The exclusive agent is required,
although no expressed commitment has been
made to use reasonable efforts and due
diligence in the expansion of the
market or the promotion of the product.
We've touched upon unconscionability
earlier in the course when we discussed
Williams versus Walker Thomas Furniture,
unconscionable contracts involved terms
that are unreasonably favorable to one
party.
In that sense,
there is a similarity between them
and the sea and this contract,
if we read it literally a between
woods and Lady Duff Gordon.
But note the important difference.
Unconscionable contracts,
the one sided pre present
mutual obligations and courts
declined to enforce them
because they were forged through an unfair
procedure that led to unfair results
by contract.
The one sided contract at issue here.
In this case of Lady Duff Gordon,
uh,
appeared to lack mutuality,
but the court rendered the contract
less one sided by reading into it and
implied obligation of reasonable effort.
Cardozo apparently felt the,
the one sidedness was not a
product of procedural defect,
but merely an imperfect expression
of the actual exchange promises.
Reading these two different kinds of cases
together teaches that courts have two
starkly different ways of
responding to one sidedness, uh,
either by refusing to enforce
them or by making them more once,
uh, by making them less one
sided by finding implied, uh,
uh,
returned promises as consideration
as we've already mentioned,
Cardozo's opinion reversed the
decision of the appellate division,
which unanimously agreed.
It quote quite apparent that the defendant
gives everything and the plaintiff
nothing and there's a lack of mutuality
and the contract indeed Cardoza his own
court was split four.
Three.
Why can't parties too exclusive dealing
contract simply include good faith or
reasonable effort clauses into their
agreements if they want to have them,
uh,
clothed with consideration.
Wouldn't that obviate the
need for implied promises?
Did Cardozo in this decision and
the UCC choose the best default.